the vision and Scarlet Witch have had an
interesting romantic relationship both
in the movies and in comics however
there's a lot of weird stuff about their
love affair that nobody seems to talk
about these are just a few are the
weirdest wackiest and most disturbing
things about Scarlet Witch and visions
relationship might as well get this out
of the way immediately the vision is a
robot he was created by another robots
to villainous Ultron who had the intent
of using him to destroy the Avengers in
the comics vision has variously been
described as an Android and as a
synthezoid but he's never described as
being a human because well he's not he's
a machine Scarlet Witch aka Wanda
Maximoff is not a robot
she's a human being and there's nothing
mechanical about her so how can a human
and a robot be involved in a romantic
relationship he's a robot even capable
of giving consent to such an arrangement
in the comics vision has long held a
desire to know what it means to become
human it's part of what drives him to
become involved with Scarlet Witch to
begin with but he'll never be a human
and no matter how closely his mainframe
mimics a human beings thoughts and
feelings he's still severely lacking in
the emotions department as for Scarlet
Witch she bonds with vision because both
of them are outcasts among their fellow
Avengers and while she might think she's
found a kindred spirit in vision what
she's really found is in a word
artificial even if she succeeds in
tricking herself into thinking their
relationship makes sense the films of
the Marvel Cinematic Universe do a lot
of things incredibly well after all
there's a reason why the franchise has
grossed more than double the take of its
closest competitor at the worldwide box
office but if there's one thing the
film's haven't done a very good job of
that's selling the audience on Scarlet
Witch and visions relationship while
both characters are introduced in
Avengers age of Ultron it isn't until
Captain America's Civil War that their
relationship starts to develop and it
does so under some pretty unsettling
circumstances one scene in particular
that stands out is when vision goes to
Wanda's room to check on her instead of
knocking on her door and asking to enter
like a normal human would vision uses
his phasing power to coast through her
wall without saying a word
completely barging in on her Wanda
rightly calls him out on his creepy
behavior and vision apologizes and makes
up word by later trying to
keep her from leaving the mansion he
says he's protecting her but that's not
his decision to make
visions wanton disregard of Wanda's
requests and his desire to control her
actions are both major red flags
not exactly boyfriend material andhe
after the initial awkwardness of visions
uncomfortable flirting and civil war he
and Scarlet Witch get into a physical
altercation when she tries to leave the
house hated by Hawkeye who distracts
vision Wanda uses her powers to force
vision through numerous floors leaving
him trapped so she can escape we know he
was being a jerk but still there's no
excuse for resorting to that level of
violence after Wanda please she joins
team cap in opposing the superhero
restricting sokovia accords vision
meanwhile is a beam of logic and not
emotion so he sides with Team Iron Man
in support of the Accords this leads to
a giant confrontation between the two
groups at a German airports with vision
and Scarlet Witch engaging in the battle
on opposing sides although the two don't
directly fight one another they're still
using near lethal force against their
friends and either one of them could
have taken the other out by accident
in fact this almost happens after vision
uses his solar beam to cut down a tower
in an attempt to block the path of the
fleeing Captain America and Winter
Soldier Scarlet Witch uses her hex
powers to keep the tower from falling
but it drops anyway after war machine
hits her with a sonic attack leaving her
very close to becoming seriously injured
as a result of visions initial assault
after this the two apologized to each
other but that doesn't excuse the fact
that they almost killed each other to
begin with in the MCU things between
vision and Scarlet Witch haven't
progressed beyond the point of living
together but they go much much further
in the comics the duo gets married in
1975 s giant-sized Avengers number four
in a dual ceremony alongside their
fellow Avengers mantas and the swordsman
technically it isn't really the
swordsman but rather a plant alien
inhabiting the swordsman's corpse making
vision and scarlet witch's wedding only
the second strangest nuptials to take
place that day comic books can be very
weird sometimes well the heart wants
what it wants
speaking of weird vision asked Scarlet
Witch to marry him immediately after the
two of them fights and defeats some
demons in another dimension when
accepting his proposal Wanda says don't
you see love is for souls not bodies
this of course makes zero sense vision
is a synthetic human the one thing he
definitely has is a body but he most
certainly does not have a soul in the
traditional sense we're not really sure
what Scarlet Witch was getting at here
but she unintentionally makes the
argument against marrying vision for D
and slip perhaps
okay so Scarlet Witch a human illegally
marries vision a robot who may or may
not have the capacity to love or fully
understand entering into a commitment
like wedlock do you think that would be
the strangest thing about this couple
but you'd be wrong because Scarlet Witch
and vision actually have kids yes you
heard that right
a robot man father's children with a
human woman now without getting into a
biology lesson here let's just say that
such a feat would be impossible humans
can't even mate with other organic
species let alone machines but the
comics get around this impossibility by
way of wait for it scarlet which
explains the vision that she conceived
when magic from some defeated witches
was funneled through her as vision held
her saying that while it was happening
she wished for a child
yikes after having a relatively normal
pregnancy Wanda gives birth to twin boys
William and Tommy in 1986 is the vision
and the Scarlet Witch number 12 and his
story titled double-sized climax it
can't make this stuff up folks just a
few years after Scarlet Witch envisioned
defy the odds and have children those
kids are taken away from them and one of
the most cruel and unusual ways possible
how does that happen
easy they were retcon in 1989's avengers
west coast number 52 the demon Mephisto
while using a possessed man called
master pandemonium as his unwitting pawn
absorbs the twins into his own body
making them master pandemonium's hands
comics everybody
apparently Thomas and William were not
actual people rather they were fragments
of Mephisto soul that had manifested
into childlike apparitions by way of the
magic Scarlet Witch used to get herself
pregnant you know that old chestnut for
a long time the status quo remained that
Scarlet Witch envisions kids were not
real this understandably caused great
strain on their relationship and it also
had a tremendous effect on Wanda's life
moving forward the memory or in some
storylines where she was an easy act
missing
Marie of her children drove Scarlet
Witch mad and a multiple time she lashed
out with earth-changing consequences at
some point the writers at Marvel must
have felt bad for her because they
decided to pull another retcon and
declare that Scarlet Witch envisions
kids existed after all we know we know
make up your mind already Marvel and the
comic series young Avengers in 2005 were
introduced to two members of the titular
team Wiccan aka William and speak real
name Thomas sound familiar
they're both mutants with Wiccan having
similar powers to Scarlet Witch and
speed having the same power set the
scarlet witch's twin brother Quicksilver
the two youngsters soon discover that
their long-lost twin brothers and not
only that but they claim they're the
same William and Thomas who were the
sons of Scarlet Witch envisioned after
some hemming and hawing everyone agrees
that they are the kids of the two
Avengers as it's explained that Wiccan
and speed are the reincarnated souls of
the long thought non-existent magical
offspring can non existent beings have
souls in a world where robots can make
babies why not
we already briefly mentioned how Scarlet
Witch has gone a little nuts a few times
and done some pretty bad reality warping
stuff that we really don't have time to
get into well one of those times marked
the end of her on-again off-again
relationship with vision after losing
control of her powers and falling under
the control of the villainous dr. doom
in the 2004 comic book storyline
Avengers disassembled Wanda launches a
series of attacks on the Avengers one of
these assaults involves her taking
control of visions body and having them
crash and jet into Avengers mansion
vision survives the crash but Wanda uses
her powers to make she-hulk rip vision
in half killing him once again vision is
rebuilt but this event proves to be the
final straw for his relationship with
Wanda during the 2012 Avengers vs. x-men
storyline vision finally gets the chance
to confront Wanda about what she did to
him he essentially tells her that her
actions were unforgivable regardless of
the fact that she wasn't in control of
her mind when she committed them this
marks the end of the Paris decades-long
relationship in the comics oh that's not
whacky enough for you okay let's see
what we can scrounge up ready here we go
although his former wife is now out of
the picture vision still feels the need
for a relationship as part of his
never-ending quest to become a real boy
and let's face it Gideon
dates is hard enough for a regular guy
let alone an Android with two
reincarnated and or imaginary and/or
demon kids and an ex-wife who literally
killed him so what's a vision to do but
creates himself a new wife in his own
image and in the 2016 self-titled comic
book series vision that's exactly what
he does yep
vision creates himself a synthezoid wife
named Virginia and he even uses Wanda's
brainwaves to do so effectively giving
her the mind of his ex he then uses
their combined brainwaves to create two
children son ving and daughter viv they
live in the suburbs and Ben and Viv
attend school everything is great for
about five seconds then the villain Grim
Reaper invades their home in a tax fit
stabbing her through the stomach with
his side he's killed by Virginia who
buries him in their backyard
Virginia's actions then lead to the
death of Viv's friend from school when
the kids father attempts to blackmail
her he shoots at Virginia but thanks to
her abilities the bullets phased through
her and while they connect with the
boy's skull from there things just get
worse Virginia kills the family dog that
vision created Ben is killed by the
Ultron created Android Victor Mancha
whom vision considered a brother
and finally Virginia kills herself after
confessing to her crimes the sole
survivor of the family aside from vision
himself of course is his daughter bid
she ends up befriending Scarlet Witch
reuniting with their dog repaired in a
joint effort by Wanda and Tony Stark and
continuing her life as a teenage
synthezoid the comic ends with vision
repairing his wife and promptly starting
the whole shebang over again suddenly
the vision in scarlet witch's
relationship doesn't sound so strange
huh
raise your hand if you're stoked for
Wanda vision check out one of our newest
videos right here plus even more looper
videos about your favorite stuff or
coming soon subscribe to our YouTube
channel and hit the bell so you don't
miss a single one
[Music]